ان انتصر في الاحتفاليه مونديال قطر 2022
ولم يبقى سوى اسبوعين تقريبا ليصدر الستار
عن اكبر حدث رياضيا وثقافيا في العالم
العربي والشرق اوسط منذ عقود طويله
الاسابيع الثلاثه الماضيه كانت مليئه
بالشغف والاثاره على مستوى المنافسه
الرياضيه في الملاعب ملعب كاس العالم
وكذلك على مستوى الحضور الله
للجماهير العاشقه لكره القدم والتي زحفت
خلف منتخباتها من كل بقاع الارض تشجيع
والمؤازره
ونقلت كاميرات الاعلام الكثير من التفاعل
الجماهيري والفعاليات الثقافيه والفنيه
التي تركت انطباعا ايجابيا كبيرا لدى
الجمهور المتواجد في قطر اليوم مشاهدينا
الكرام لصديق اثنين من المؤثرين همم العرب
في نقترب اا معهم اكثر من تفاصيل تجربتهم
التي يعيشوها في قطر خلال الفتره الماضيه
ونسعد ايضا باستقبال اسئلتكم لتوجيها
لضيوفنا تباعا خلال هذا مباشر معنا هند
زيادي همم الفنانه المغربيه والمؤثره كذلك
وهمم سامي الذي سالحق بنا بعد قليل وسامي
الشافعي هو واحد من صناع المحتوى
والمؤثرين من تونس همم طيب هند ابدا معك
مبدئيا انت همم انت حضرتك كاس العالم
في قطر دي كانت اول مره اول مره لك تحضري
كاس عالم او فعاليه بهذا الشكل
[موسيقى]
تحياتي
قصدا انه المنتخب
به
منظم دوله عربي هذا وحش يكون
اكثر زيد واحد واحد شويه فكانت اول مره
صراحه
من حضورك
[موسيقى]
التنظيم
الامور اللوجستيه على مستوى الاستدادات
على مستوى التنقلات السفر همم الاحتياجات
اللي اي مشجع بيبقى محتاجها في بلد لقيت
فيها متوفره ولا لا يعني ممكن نبدا الاول
من حيث وصلت هند للمطار هل الاجراءات اه
سامي اهلا وسهلا اهلا وسهلا بك
يبقى كيف حالكم لاباس عليكم يا اهلا وسهلا
بيك
طيب انا انا حابب
اولا عن انطباعه عن عن حضوره الكاس العالم
منذ وضعت قدمه مطار الدوحه اول ما نزل
كانت الامور والاجراءات عامله ازاي
امم انا هو
في الاول انا كان عندي تخوف اوكي
مشيت مع صديقتي دعوه من عند الفيفا وكان
عندي
بوحدي وبنات فما عارفه الاجراءات كيفاش
غادي يكونوا يعني اول مره تمشي للدوله
خليجيه لكن همم
اللي كان في قطر صريح يعني كان اكثر من
رائع كتحسبوا حتى سلاسه في المرور في
المطار حتى في الخارج يعني ما لناش وصلنا
كانت الامور يعني ثلاثه بسهوله يعني ما
كانت صعوبه في المطار ولا حتى شيء حاجه
فتخرجنا نفس الشيء يعني التنقل كان كان
سهل بس وصلنا المطار المترو ديسكو ههه
بترد ههه
هذه الموضوع سهل جدا
تمام سامي
هنا
اول مره
قالت هند قلت كنت خايف من الوورد كاب انه
مثل الكل يروحوا لنفس البلد صغير
في تاريخ المباراه في تاريخ الورد
[موسيقى]
النظام
كلنا على نفس الصوره قلنا مؤثرين ومش
مؤثرين وهذا يعني اختصارا على كل شيء اول
مره تحضر
اول مره
قبل كده
تمام تمام
بكره القدم
[موسيقى]
ههه
بالضبط
[ضحك]
ههه
طيب يعني انت علاقتك بالكوره هي بس انك
انت بتشجعي المنتخب لما بيلعب همم في
مباريات كبيره في امم افريقيا او في كاس
العالم ولا لا انت عندك فريق كمان في
المغرب بتشجعيه
يعني انا كانحس بها مناش كيكون المنتخب
هذا ماشي فرقه كتلعب هذاك المغرب يعني
الوطنيه المنتخب
ههه
تمام يعني انت ماشيه وراء وراء العالم
وراء الوطن اينما كان الوطن هنروح نشجعه
موسيقى ههه
اكثر من كاس العرب
[موسيقى]
ومنطلق المنتخب صعد وهيلعب في ال 16 مع
اسبانيا بكره مغربي
ماشي فقط زعلا
توحد اللي كانتمناه يكون دائما ماشي غير
في الكون انه فغيمو واحد واحد الشعوب
العربيه صراحه وكنتمنى ديما يكون هذا الحب
هذا مشترك بيناتنا
بلد عربي
بشكل كبير في كاس العرب
بتاعه الدول العربيه همم الاناشيد الوطنيه
ربما في ظل دائما المشحنات
في السياسيه اللي بتحصل في العالم العربي
بتغيب ال- همم العواطف عواطف والمشاعر
الصادقه والترابط دوت ما بين الشعوب
العربيه نوعا ما يعني لكن ترجع تظهر في
همم المحكات ديت بشكل كبير طيب همم اول
مباراه حضرتوها في اي استاد
وكلموني عن شعوركم كده وانتم داخلين
الاستاد اللي مليان جمهور كده مش اقل من
50 60 الف متفرج
همم اول مباراه هي مباراه قطر
[موسيقى]
وشفت جونكوك
الكوري اللي هو عمل بالفرنس مش عاديه
ما كنت نستنى
كاس العرب
[موسيقى]
وين طريقه كلهم كلهم على ال ولكمنج على
الترحيب كلهم عريس كلهم على طول كلهم وحتى
مورجان فريمان
يحكي على
السؤال هو كيف نقبله بعضنا الكل كله
ديمه همم نقبله بعضنا رغم اختلافاتنا في
كل شيء وهذا من احلى من احلى ما شفتها
افتتاحات الحق ما عنده
تمام تمام
قال لا نحضر حتى انا حضرت الافتتاح
الاوبنينج واحضرت القطر واكوادور فكان
يعني كانت تاسفنا بزاف لانه قطر ما كانش
يعني في اول مباراه ديالها مدفوقهاش انها
تفوز ولكن كيف ما قال الاخ سامي كان واحد
العرض خيالي بزاف
عالميه كتشوفها تماك يعني كتحس انها دوله
عربيه
بالموسيقى كانوا وجه التحيه للرضوان اللي
دار واحد الخدمه
ههه
دار الواحد مجهود زوين موسيقى كانت رائعه
اغاني كثير من البوم كاس العالم
[موسيقى]
في تعليق مخليهم مخليهم ما قالوا انا
محاضر في فيديو على الموضوع هذا اللي هو
بتكون سبيب نحكي على على خاطر بلد عربي
وسله عمل حاجه ما وصلتش عملته بالطريقه
هذه ببلد اخرى وصرت غيرها مش
فما ثم ثم
النوعين من غير هم الغيره اللي تخليك تخدم
اكثر فما الغيره
عند العرب
همم نزلت فيديو بتاع ارجنتينيو يظهر
امريكي
اتجاه بعض الحاجات اللي انت ممكن اا تكوني
قلقانه منها لما تحضري يعني كان في كلام
كثير على ان قطر بلد صغيره مش هتقدر
تستوعب هذا الكم من الجماهير اللي هيجيء
يحضر ربما على مستوى الاقامه والسكن هيبقى
في مشكله لان الاقامه والسكن محدود في قطر
زي ما كانت الانتقادات بتقوله بتقل
الاسعار هتكون غاليه جدا همم هل ده اشياء
وجهتوها ولا
لما جئتوا
المونديال وهمم وحضرته واجهته الامور ديت
لقيتوها مختلفه عن مكان يشاع يعني
الصدى الجلد التشويش اللي كان واقع على
قطر
شويه اصدقاء
[موسيقى]
طيب صغاري راه
احسنوا كايتروج ليه لانه اكيد دوله عربيه
اول دوله عربيه كانتنضم المونديال راه
ماشي شي حاجه ساهله اكيد يقبلها ما غادي
يشوفوا يعني كيتسناو غير شي حاجه فيني
غلطتوا بس يعني نزلوا عليهم ولكن صراحه
كان ممكن ما كانقولوا قدها ويادود يعني
همم كانوا قد التحدي
شوف باش نكون نكون معك صريحه اوكي يعني ما
نكذبش معاك ما نكذبش عليك هو الاسعار كانت
غاليه ولكن انا انو طبيعي علاج
دوله قطر
نكون معكم واضح وكما نكذب انا ما عندي حتى
تفكري على الاسعار لانهم ساكنين
ما خلص شيء
الاسعار وكل شيء ولكن
[موسيقى]
يصير نفس الحاجه اللي قالتها هند هو انه
مستوي
رز وكل شيء يخلي الناس انه همم تقدر همم
على الكريه ولا على الكريه واللي هو يكون
يكون مرفق فهمت ولكن بالنسبه لجين من تونس
ولا اصحابي مثلا من تونس
واحد ارجع لهم حاجه عاديه خاطر هم الثلاثه
مباريات تونس كنت بالنسبه فهمت لازم همم
يبحث على الاقامات يلقى يلقى الحل يعني
كان في اوبشنز انت بقى عايز تقول ان كان
في اوبشنز
عشان نكون واضحين فيه نفس الحاجه شوف انا
نقول حاجه قبل اللي كانت في روس
الشعر
وعنده سعر ترانسبورت اغلى يرجع نفس الحاجه
في الاخر بنفس الاسعار همم
حضرت
الواحد ولكن الجزء المباريات كانت ديال
قطر
وكنت جلد المنتخب يعني اول ماتش ليه
فاحضرت
من ناحيه
الفقرات الداخليه
من ناحيه الدخول والخروج والانسيابيه
والحاجات دي كلها كان وضعها عامل ازاي
صغيره وكل شيء منظم
تبقى كتعجب بالحق كاتكون عاود في نفس
الوقت انك مفتخر وافتخر بهذا الشيء هذا
نشوف في اليابان يعني قلب ساعتين فهمت شوف
نحب نقارن كاس العرب
همم
نجم يكون مرات تكون هوسبيتاليتي ولا حتى
تكون همم تكت نورمل تغلط وبيخليك تدخل
وهما مو مش فاهمين رويحهم اثنين تعلموا من
اغلاهم بتاع همم كاس العرب حتى غلطه متعود
تفوز بيرفكت
مركز يعني انا نقول لهم انا من نفقه
العالم مثلا حاجه
قلتها من الاول ولكن مره يهدي الورد
اللي انا بالنسبه لي شفت كل حاجه فيها قصه
وراها انها اي لف توريتينك اي حاجه فيها
قصه وراها انا بحبها اكثر وهذا الاسم
اللي يعجبوني
وعجبتني القصه انت وعجبتني انه بشي فرق
يعني مركب وبيش ناحيه واو
بالمناسبه استاذ 9 7 4 هو اخر مباراه
هتتلعب فيه هي المباراه النهارده
انتهت من حوالي نصف ساعه ما بين البرازيل
وكوريا الجنوبيه وفي كلام ان ال- الاستاد
هيتفكك والله اعلم هيتنقل اي دوله تونس
مبروك مبروك عليكم الاستاذ شكرا شكرا
[ضحك]
انا حضرتك كاس العالم في
روسيا كمان مباشر
هي فكره الجماهير اللي جايين من الدول
العالم
يعني فكره ان الواحد بيشوف حد
من البرازيل والارجنتين وامريكا واسبانيا
وايطاليا وانجلترا وكوريا واليابان وكل
دول مع بعض ثقافات مختلفه خلفيات فكريه
مختلفه لغات مختلفه همم همم اشكال مختلفه
انتم ازاي قدرتوا انكم انتم يعني هل ليكم
قصه مع هذا التنوع هل تواصلتوا مع جمهور
بلدان مختلفه من الموجودين هل كونتوا
صدقات بالمناسبه يا سامي يعني في كاس
العالم اللي في روسيا تقريبا كان فيه
30,000 شاب تونسي ومغربي اتجوزوا ههه
في كاس العالم اللي فات
ههه
طيب احكوا لنا على قصصكم في التواصل مع مع
الجماهير المختلفه اللي من الدول المختلفه
دي
تبدا هند هند
مع العالم كامل وحتى
يعني يعني اقرب
الناس
كل شيء
عالم كامل كهنئك فواحد شكرا
[موسيقى]
الباشن هيدي عندي كل وهما وهما حبوا
الحاجه دي وريتهم تونس اكثر وريتهم اكثر
وهذا هو ال- ال-
اهم حاجه تصير في وسط همم في وسط
كما هذا يجيبوا الجنسيات من العالم الكل
فهمت
قبيله همم
من غير ما يحكم عليك من غير ما يحكم عليه
شنو انت تحب مهما كان عمرك وهي همم بنحب
نقول مناسبه هذه لانه ثقافه مفتوحه من هذه
الانمي تعلمت منها همم القيم الكل في
الحقيقه القيام صديق الحب همم تيمورك
يابانيه مثلا ولا ايه لان واضح ان الحب
الحب معدي ههه
عندي
اكيد كل الورد
تلقاني مثل يبقى ههه
طيب لما لما بتحكوا للناس عن عن المغرب او
تونس الناس اللي من الدول المختلفه او من
يعني ايه هل في حاجه كانت مثيره للاهتمام
استقبلتوها هل في احد مثلا تكلم عن المغرب
قال حاجه لافته جدا او تكلم عن تونس على
حاجه مهمه جدا ربما انتم حتى ما كنتوش همم
واخذين بالكم منها بشكل او باخر
مثل مثل يعني يعرف حاجه على بلادك انت ما
عرفتني
يعني هل في شيء ما كان مثير للاهتمام
بالنسبه لهم
تصاور البلد
بالتفاصيل يظهر لي اكثر مني فهمت
هند عندك قصه حاضره في دماغك حصلت لك في
كاس العالم في الفتره اللي انت كنت متعوده
فيها وحاسه ان هي كان شيء يعني مهم انك
انت تحكيه دايما للناس بعد كده
لابسين التوني ديال المغرب
عن الشعوب العربيه ربما تكون اختلفت بشكل
كبير جدا الناس يعني راحوا انطباعات
ورجعوا من تبعات ثانيه مختلفه
غصب عنكم يعني
العرب
المغرب
[موسيقى]
سامي موافقه على الكلام هند
طيب يعني احنا تكلمنا دلوقتي عن عن عن
امور كثير جدا جزء منها بشكل كبير جدا
انتم اتكلمتوا عن انطباعاتكم واتجاه
المونديال طيب
ايه هي سلبيات اللي انتم شفتوها
يعني لو كانت اتظبطت او كانت تعدلت بشكل
مختلف كانت هتبقى اضافه اكثر واكثر
انا الحاجه الوحيده من منقول سلبيه انا
نعرف الحاجه ديت صارت لتنظيف ولكن اكثر
حاجه
لشخصين تعبتني برشا و تعبت حتى الفريق
الفريق التصوير الموجود في قطر الكل كلهم
يحتوي على نفس الحاجه انه
الفانفيس تروح الاستيديو خصك تمشي على
رجليك اكثر من اربعه كيلو متر
يعني
في اول
نوكياكس والخط الطويل
الخط تقريبا على مستوى مثل على مستوى رايح
الفتح فيسبوك مثلا
الاوبر والالباس
ولا المترو يخليك في يخليك بعيده يعني
خليك في مكان بعيد على على
ثلاثه كيلو متر
اعمل طعم المضاعف متاحه
لانه عمل لك مش عامل لك خط واحد عمل لك
متاهه اطول
الحاجه دي ولا 200 فما طرقات مغلقه همم
[موسيقى]
لاي مكان اقبال ساعتين تمام
في عشان خاطر تبقى الصوره مكتمله اكتر في
المونديال
ههه
وكنت كنتمنى انه يكون التيكيت موجودين
اكثر وما يكونش هذا المشكله
[موسيقى]
يعني
الموضوع يكون صحيح
هديه الحاجه اللي كنتمنى انها انها تكون
تكون هذه المره هذه ولكن نتمنى من هنا
للغده يكون خير نتمنى انهم يدخلوهم
للملعب لانه حاجه ضروري الجمهور يعني
كيعطي واحد نقدر نقول لك واحد 50 اكثر
[موسيقى]
على الايسي على المكيف والله
اليوم في الجزيره معهم هاشتاج
[ضحك]
فالناس اتعودت على
الجو البرد شويه من التكييف يعني بس ربما
الناس اللي جايين من بره الوضع بالنسبه
لهم بيكون مختلف
والله وعاود مرات يعني من وراء يعاود حلقي
يعني كل مره ولكن ديت كان فهمتني يعني
خلاص كل مره كان نفوت على مكان كيكون فيه
الايشي كانحاول
التفاح ههه
لا احنا كده خلاص هنركز في موضوع الاي سي
بقى احنا بنوجه الرساله
للمنظمين ان هم يقللوا من درجه حراره درجه
حراره الاستاد شويه
همم
طيب همم كلموني انتم احنا تكلمنا على
الجمهور اللي من جوه المختلفه ماذا عن
الدوله جمهور الدوله المستضيفه القطبيين
نفسهم والمقيمين في قطر نفسهم هل تواصلوا
معهم محتاجته بهم وتعاملته معهم بشكل او
باخر همم
ظهر لكم ايه من خلال تجربتكم في التعامل
معها ههه
انا تعاملت مع قطريين وما احلاهم على
الاخر مستضيفين
كل مره
شخص يربح لي قلبي يهزني في مكان في مكان
وفيلم بنيناس
[ضحك]
ههه الجمهور
[موسيقى]
جمهور قطري محليه والناس القطريين جمهور
البلاد
[موسيقى]
تعرفت على قطريين في البيت
مع الزوج
امم طيب
في ما يتعلق باداء المنتخبات العربيه بقى
احنا هنفضل هنفضل امتى
لاعب حلو
وخروج خروج مشرف للمنتخب السعودي
والله شوف انا تعبت من كلمه
الكره
ثلاثه ثلاثه
مع الكوره لا شيء مستحيل كوشي ممكن ههه
متوقعين ايه الماتش بكره
من غير عوض
قوي جدا
ريفانز لان نقبل في الوورد كاب يقبل همم
مغرب لعبه ضد اسبانيا وكانه اثنين اثنين
صح اه يعني رجوع همم
مش هنعرف يعني نستضيفك يا هند همم من غير
ما ت همم تغني اغنيه للمغرب
يلا
مغيب مغيرين عملت الروح منزار بلادنا بحبه
يروح الله على الريف ورجاله
تحيه لكل جمانه الله على الريف ورجع
نا تحيه لكل جباله والصحراوي
[موسيقى]
بس كده
وكمان اغنيه
يعني عشان خاطر الجمهور المغربي
[موسيقى]
دور الثمانيه تبقى دي اول مره في تاريخ
كاس العالم
لدور الثمانيه
المغرب يعني الاولى في المجموعه ديالها
يعني في مجموعه الموت هي الاولى
انجاز تاريخي وان شاء الله يا ربي غدا
يكون انجاز عربي عالمي
طيب كلمه اخيره بقى
شكرا على الاستضافه شكرا
على مثل العالم العربي
[موسيقى]
كلمه اخيره
المغرب
[موسيقى]
العربي
بقى ان شاء الله
ده حاجه ثانيه كاس العالم لايف كده ههه
هنغني كثير بقى ههه
وانا كمان بشكر كل المشاهدين والمتابعين
اللي انا حبيت ان انا انقل اسئلتهم فعلا
بس همم الوقت كان كان ضيق وان شاء الله
باذن الله كده كل دعواتنا للمغرب بكره
ربنا يوفقك
وان شاء الله نشوفكم على خير ثاني باذن
الله شكرا جزيلا